don't lead with a complaint so just
finished filming my weekly videos at
trial date salsa and the first guy who
showed up was complaining first thing
first thing I was found was complaining
about how much of work he had how busy
he felt I wasn't sleeping next guy shows
up starts complaining about how hot it
is in the studio because we we turn off
the air conditioning doesn't make noise
or two when we're filming hey you know
in general complaining is not a great
thing you know and Here I am plugging
the book complainers you look at super
successful people and they don't usually
complain much right like they're not
human players they have bad things
happen to them sure maybe more than most
of us and they plow through when they
accept responsibility and they do
something about it but they don't
complain with my breath doesn't go up
the stairs here still with stairwell
rained and so I challenged them to say
listen don't make your first interaction
with somebody for the next week don't
make it a complaint like don't be that
person who's known as the guy a girl
who's always complaining how does that
make people feel around here in response
was well Evan I know you you know known
you for a while it's not like I'm
talking to a customer and for sure like
if you're talking to a customer the
first thing I promised complaint man
like you hate your life there's a whole
bunch of stuff you gotta fix there but
why is it that when you do with your
friends or people close to you that's
okay to lead with a complaint how is
that okay
and so I'll use the example listen if
you're secured going home take my shoe
off and you're meeting your wife or your
wife is coming home which is meeting you
do you want the first thing out of your
mouth to be a complaint like do you want
the first thing I'm her mouth to be a
complaint is that what you want to like
that's the relationship that you want to
have wouldn't be better to say something
like hey it's great to see you i don't
know something something more than just
a complaint the people that you work
with to your boss if you have a job how
about you not be known as a person who
just always is complaining but has
something positive to say when they lead
off just a mindset shift and by the same
token also say try to end not on a
complaint like whatever the last
interaction with you is if you're
hanging up a phone call if you're you
know leaving and seeing a bye in person
whatever it is try to end them on a
positive note i definitely don't end the
complaint now i know life is not perfect
i know we all have stuff that's
happening and no one gets on our nerves
and yeah in an ideal world nobody's
complaining and the super successful
people don't complain but i think your
first step kind of towards that is for
the next week and i'm going to do this
to like i don't i don't i'm not sitting
on some high rock and saying i have all
the answers and I don't make any
mistakes like maybe I do some
complaining when I first meet somebody
you know especially the people close to
me there's a challenge for me too but
you know my challenge for you is for the
next week try to go in to every single
interaction with another human being and
not lead with some kind of complaint
right if somebody asks you how your day
is going and it may be the worst day
you've ever had still try to leave with
something a little bit positive like I'm
really glad to be seeing you here today
something like show a little bit of
gratitude and appreciation because you
know what like as because you think your
problems are right now your grandparents
had it worse your great-grandparents had
it works there's a billion people in the
world right now who would kill to have
the life that you have right now and the
problems that you have in
life right now so stop complaining and
definitely don't lead or any or end any
conversation any interaction with the
complaint that's your challenge my
challenge for the week stairwell rant